TO OUR APRIL FOURTH.
MEETING OF BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
THREE ON RESOURCES AND
TRANSPORTATION.
BOB GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL HERE
THIS MORNING WE HAVE A
RELATIVELY LIGHT AGENDA SO I
DON'T TO EXPECT WILL BE PUSHING
THE LIMITS AS WE. FREQUENTLY DO.
OF COURSE OF THE DAY AND WE'RE
GONNA WELCOME A. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA WHO IS.
BEEN.
OF THIS WEEK APPOINTED AS AN
ALTERNATE
TO THE COMMITTEE SO WELCOMES
COULD HAVE YOU HERE.
WILL.
AS A BEGIN OUR MEETING GO WHILE
WE WAIT FOR QUORUM.
WITH.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
ITEM FOLLOWED BY ISSUE TO.
THE MORNING.
PLEASE PROCEED.
SARGIS TERM.
RON.
CHAIR BLOOM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I JUST WIRE BRIEFLY I'M SPEAK
TO THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS KIND OF UPDATED STATUS
WHERE THINGS ARE TODAY.
APRIL TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
SO THAT TODAY THEIR CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS HAS ABOUT
THIRTEEN HUNDRED.
HUNDRED FIFTY CORPS MEMBERS
WORKING THROUGHOUT.
.
TWENTY FOR CENTERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AWAY
FROM NATIONAL CITY SAN DIEGO UP
TO.
READING IN Y. RICA AND OF THOSE
TWENTY FOUR CENTERS.
THAT'S NOTED IN THE ALEJO'S
REPORT.
EIGHT OF THEM ARE RESIDENTIAL
CENTERS WERE YOUNG PEOPLE STAY
AND LIVE AT OUR HOUSE SPEAKER
THAT.
A LITTLE BIT TOWN.
LATER.
WE'VE WHO WERE HOPING
EMERGENCIES ARE DONE FOR AWHILE.
CALPERS IN BACK OF US I THINK
THERE.
HOPING THE SAME RELEASED I AM
THAT TERRIBLE.
THEN OVER EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOURS OF.
EMERGENCIES
SERVICE WORK THIS PAST YEAR.
OVER SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND HOURS
AND FIRES
AND A COUPLE HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOURS PROMINENT IN A LOT OF
FLOOD WORK OPPOSE THOMAS FIRE.
AND EVEN A FEW THOUSAND HOURS OF
BET FLY ERADICATION AND OTHER
THINGS IS NEEDED START SPENT A
BUSY. YEAR FOR US AS WELL AS
EVERYONE ELSE.
RELATED TO OUR OUR RESIDENTIAL
EXPANSION NO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GET INTO TODAY BUT.
I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT.
YEAH IT'S FANTASTIC
IT'S GREAT THAT OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE IS AND STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS AROUND FOUR POINT THREE
PERCENT.
BUT IN KERN COUNTY.
PROVIDED HIS ESPECIALLY FOR A
SUMMARY SOME REMEMBER A FONG
BUTTON KERN COUNTY SITE POINT
SIX PERCENT.
OUR MEN AND TO HATCH A P. IN
KERN COUNTY IT'S TO A POINT
WHERE IT IS TEN POINT EIGHT
PERCENT SO WHERE THE STATE IS
THRIVING. THERE'S STILL COUNTIES
AND COMMUNITIES THAT AREN'T
DOING AS WELL IN FRESNO COUNTY.
WHERE ARE ARE VERY RESIDENTIAL
SITE WILL BE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
IS AT NINE POINT ONE PERCENT
SO THERE'S CERTAINLY A NEED?
AND I THINK OUR RESIDENTIAL
CENTERS AND WHAT THE COURT DOES.
REALLY SPEAKS TO.
AND ADDRESSES OUT UNEMPLOYMENT.
ISSUE AND IN PARTICULAR ARE
CORMORANT UP THOSE THIRTEEN
HUNDRED FOURTEEN UNDER CORMAN'S
I REFERRED TO.
THIRTY PERCENT.
OUR LATINO.
.
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY PERCENT
ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN.
A TEN PERCENT ARE ASIAN AND
OTHER SONY OVER OR NEARLY SIXTY
SARAH OF OUR CORE MEMBER
POPULATION.
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR.
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT WOMEN OUT OF
OUR DEMOS THIRTEENERS FORTUNATE
CRUMBS SO THERE. IT'S NOT JUST
AN ISSUE OF.
NEED THE NEED FOR THESE
RESIDENTIAL CENTERS BUT ARE
GREATER NEED IN TERMS OF
UNEMPLOYMENT AND IN PARTICULAR
THOSE.
UNEMPLOYED YOUNG FOLKS IN THOSE
MOST UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
SO AVE QUEUE FOR HAVING US.
OR WERE HAPPY TO START THIS
PROCESS AND LOOK FORWARD TO A A
LIVELY DISCUSSION IN THE MONTHS
AHEAD.
THANK YOU.
ELIOT.
GIPSON COMMENTS.
IT WOULDN'T HAVE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS.
THE.
FINANCE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY.
ADDITIONAL PRESENTATION OF THE
IDEAL. ISSUE NUMBER ONE OR TWO.
I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE A FOLLOW
UP QUESTION FOR GREATER.
.
I.
WE WE ARE.
SO FOCUSED ON FIRE AND MUDSLIDES
AND.
.
A AND FLOODING.
PARTICULARLY OVER THE LAST YEAR
OR SO BUT YOU MENTIONED TO.
THE WORK THAT TO HAVE THE
CONSERVATION CORPS DOES ON THE
MED FLY. OUT INFESTATION I
WONDER IF YOU COULD JUST DO A
COUPLE OF MINUTES TO A BRIEFING
FOR US ON.
.
WHAT THAT'S ALL ABOUT TO REMIND
FOLKS WHO MAY BE LISTENING IN?
AND THE A WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
TWELVE CENTS THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES AND EARLY NINETEEN
EIGHTIES FOR CCC HERE. INITIALLY
GOT INVOLVED IN THE MED FLY.
RATIFICATION AND. THE THE FAMOUS
STORY THAT.
SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE HEARD OF
OUR DIRECTOR AT THAT TIME BT
COLLINS DRUNKARD CLASS OF
MOLLIFY AND I PROBABLY LIKE A
BUNCH OF OTHER FOLKS WERE THERE
BUT. PUB ALLOT OF FOLKS OF
EVERYWHERE. OUT TO PROVE THAT
THE
MALATHION WAS HARMLESS AND.
KIDS DON'T TRY THIS AT HOME YET
TRANSFORM A RUMOR IS THE GOOD
GALA SICK AFTER THAT BUT SINCE
THEN. WE'VE COULD.
SINCE THEN WE'VE CONTINUED TO.
.
UMP.
PROVIDE SUPPORT.
AND MORE RECENTLY IT'S BEEN THE
RATIFICATION MEANS ACTUAL
STRIPPING OF FRUITS SO OF.
AGRICULTURAL OF IDENTIFIED
NEIGHBORHOODS OUR COMMUNITY IS
OUR RESIDENTS WHERE. THERE ARE
FRUIT.
AND CORPS MEMBERS ARE WILL GO
IN TEAMS.
AND IDENTIFY THE HOUSE KNOCKED
ON THE DOOR. TELLING THEY'RE
GONNA.
THE FRUIT BAG UP AND THEN
DESTROY.
THEY DIDN'T.
A FEW WEEKS TWO THOUSAND HOURS
OF WORK.
THE LATEST LAST DECEMBER.
AND WE JUST RESPOND WHENEVER AG
SAYS THERE'S A PROBLEM AGAIN
BUT AGAIN MOST OF THE RECENT
WORK HAS BEEN IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY MOST AROUND.
I'VE SUNLAND PROCLAIM AREA.
IN COUNCIL DISTRICTS SEVEN AND
SIX I BELIEVE.
GREAT THANK YOU FOR FOR THE
REPORT JOB DID YOU WANNA ADD A
COMMENT HERE. HOW WE?
AYE WE GOING IS THIS ISSUE
NUMBER ONE AND TWO ARE WE GOING
TO GO OVER THOSE NAPSTER WAS
THAT. ARE WELL I WAS SO HOPING
IT'S ISSUES ONE AND TWO WHY DID
YOU HAVE A SEPARATE PRESENT ANY
ADDITIONAL PRESENTATION.
YESTERDAY IT'S BEEN A AND THEN
WE HAD SOME RECOMMENDATIONS ON
ASIA LOTS OF.
AND SO IN THAT YOU'VE GOT GIVEN
UP YOUR OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOUR
BLOOM. OTHER GOT RIGHT ALONG.
SO WITH REGARD TO THE GROUP'S
NUMBER COUNSELING CASE
MANAGEMENT TRANSITION TO COLLEGE
AND CAREER TRAINING AND
WHERE ARE RECOMMENDING FUNDING
THE TRANSITION SERVICES. AS A
THREE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM.
THAT WE THINK THAT THAT FUNDING
THE SERVICES COULD HAVE BENEFITS
BUT THE LACK OF DATA ON POLICY
SEE OUTCOMES MAKES IT DIFFICULT
TO FULLY X. SAT ASSESSED CORPSE
IN A NEED FOR THE SERVICES.
NEVER RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE FUND THESE ANA THAT
THREE YEAR. PERIOD AND REQUIRE
THE CCC TO COME BACK IN THREE
YEARS TO DEMONSTRATE THAT IT
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED THIS
PROGRAM. THAT WERE ALSO
RECOMMENDS LEGISLATURE ADOPT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO ACQUIRE
THE CCC TO PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH AN ANNUAL
REPORT ON THAT CORPSE IN
GRAPTEMYS. BY DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. AND THIS UC SYNDICATES
IN ITS BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT IT
INTENDS TO PUBLISH AN ANNUAL
REPORT. WE THINK WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO SPECIFY THE INFORMATION THAT
IT WOULD LIKE THE CCC TO REPORT
ON. AND THEN WITH REGARDS TO
THAT PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE CONSULTING
SERVICES THAT PART OF THE
PROPOSED WE RECOMMEND THAT YOU
APPROVE THAT WE THINK THERE'S A
NEED FOR THAT.
AND THEN WITH REGARD TOTHE
OTHER PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE
RESIDENTIAL CENTERS.
I WILL RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE
WAIT UNTIL THERE'S MORE
INFORMATION ON QUIPS MEMBER
OUTCOMES BEFORE APPROVING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
THE RESIDENTIAL CENTERS. AND WE
GOT THE CONSTRUCTING THE NEW
CENTERS MIGHT BE WORTH PURSUING
IF THE CCC CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT
THE BENEFITS ARE SIGNIFICANT
ENOUGH TO JUSTIFY THAT ONGOING
OPERATIONAL COSTS. AND THE
CAPITAL INVESTMENT IN THESE
FACILITIES.
AND THAT WE ALSO I RECOMMEND YOU
REQUIRE THIS ISSUE CEDAR REPORT
ON OUTCOMES JIM FOR LONGER TERM
POLICY CHOICES.
GREAT THANK YOU FINANCE HOUSING
HEREDEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WITH
REGARD TO ISSUE ONE WE WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE SUPPORT THE.
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE
TRANSITION SERVICES.
THANK YOU MISTER CITED YOU WANT
TO ADD ANYTHING HAVING HEARD THE
COMMENTS OF LEO. THANK YOU OR
AFFECTED YOUR GROUP SO WE WE
HAVE WORKED IN THE PAST YEAR TO
DEVELOP SOME THOSE OUTCOMES AND
AS WELL AS GOALS FOR OUR
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
THAT WE DO KNOW THAT THEIR. OF
THEIR HAVE THERE THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT OR.
DEFINITE NAM REASONS THAT OUR
RESIDENTS ARE CENTERS IN OUR
COURTROOMS ARE MORE SUCCESSFUL.
THEY HAVE HIGHER.
ENGLISH AND MATH ATTAINMENT.
OR CHI MINH'S.
THE COURT MEMBERS ARE MORE
READILY AVAILABLE TO TO RESPOND
TO THOSE EMERGENCIES BECAUSE OUR
OUR RESIDENTIAL CENTER AS
OPPOSED TO NONRESIDENTIAL
CENTER.
AND THEIR NUMBER GAINS THAT WE
THAT WE'VE.
ARE TRACKING WE NEED TO BE
BETTER AT THAT AND WERE WERE
ABSOLUTELY PREPARED TO. PROVIDE.
DOES METRIX'S OR THOSE SYSTEMS
TO BETTER COLLECT THAT DATA TO
TO PROVE THAT THESE.
A RESIDENTIAL CENTERS ARE REALLY
GREAT PROBLEM GREATLY BENEFIT
OUR RESIDENTIAL COURTROOMS.
THANK YOU.
FONG ANY QUESTIONS AND WELCOME
THANK YOU I HAVE SOME.
SOME QUICK GENERAL QUESTIONS IN.
ARE. YOU HOW DO YOU GO ABOUT
RECRUITING FOLKS TO PARTICIPATE
AND CCC AND THEN IN TERMS OF
TRACKING OUTCOMES DO YOU TRACK
CURRENTLY DO YOU HAVE ANY
INITIAL DATA.
AND WHAT ARE THE OUTCOMES THAT
HAVE OCCURRED AT FOR FOR THESE
GRADUATES.
IN GENERAL YOU COULD HEAR ALL
DIFFERENT.
RESOURCES REVIEW RECRUITER
COMMUNITY AND YOUTH GROUPS AND
CHURCHES AND EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT ARM OFFICE
A WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT OFFICES.
ARE BUT FROM ON LOT OF OUR YOUNG
FOLKS
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN AROUND FOR
TWO YEARS.
IT'S WORD OF MOUTH AND STARTS.
COUSINS TELLING THEIR. OTHER
COUSINS OR BROTHERS TOWN THEIR
SISTERS ARE SISTERS TURN THE
BROTHERS WERE. ARM AND A LOT OF
KIDS WERE FOCUSING RIGHT NOW ON.
MOTHERS
VETS ARE EVER TRY TO GET THAT
WORD OUT BECAUSE AND THAT MOM
THAT WANTS TO YOUNG FOLKS OFF
THE COUCH.
AND DO ACCEPT PRODUCTIVE WERE
AND I'M HOPING THAT REFOCUS AND
THEIR LIVES ARE. RICK WE RECRUIT
FROM EVERYONE AND EVERYWHERE.
IN TERMS OF OUR OUTCOMES.
WE NEED TO BE BETTER AT THAT WE
KNOW THAT MORE THAN THIRTY
PERCENT OF OUR YOUNG FOLKS.
EXCESS FULLY.
.
ENTERED POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
OR OR OR JOB ANNOUNCES LIES.
JOB OR CAREER. ARE WE KNOW THAT
SOME.
OUR GREAT PERCENTAGE CLOSER TO
EIGHTY OR NINETY PERCENT OF OUR
YOUNG PARK SET COMPLETE A YEAR.
AND GRADUATE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
ARE EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL AND AND
FIND WORKER REENTRY INTO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
AND LET ONE THAT'S RUSSIA IN
TERMS OF THE HISTORY OF HE SEE
HOW MANY.
COMING GRADUATES HAVE YOU HAD.
I DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER WE'VE
HAD A HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
YOUNG FOLKS THAT HAVE GONE
THROUGH THE.
.
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
IN THE FORTY ONE YEARS AND
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH A CORE
MEMBER DEVELOPMENT STAFF OF BACK
REFLECTED SEE THEN THEY'D
PROBABLY TELLING ME THAT. BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT EXACT.
NOBODY'S JUMPING R.. WELL EIGHT
THANKS GUYS THAT WHAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THAT FOR ME THAT I WILL
BE THINKING.
ALRIGHT WELL I THINK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS IS THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
NO WEALTHIEST INDIVIDUALS THAT
STEPPING FORWARD TO WE HAVE HOLD
OPEN RECOMMENDATIONS ON ALL OF
OUR ITEMS
TODAY WE HAVE INFORMED A QUORUM
YET BUT IF WE CAN FORMER
CONSENSUS ON ANY OF OUR ITEMS
THAT.
A WILL CERTAINLY TRY TO MOVE
THOSE ITEMS FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AYE DANIELLE LYNCH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES WE REPRESENT
THE PRIVATE NONPROFIT LOCAL
CONSERVATION CHORDS THAT. ARE
BASED IN WORKING IN REGIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I'M WE JUST
WANTED OFFER FULL SUPPORT FOR
ALL THE ITEMS FOR THE CCC IT
ESPECIALLY THE ONE THAT HELPS
THEM WITH. TRANSITIONAL AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES I'M YOU ALL
SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED A LETTER ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF THAT LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES AND WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT. THEIR
BUDGET ITEM FOR TRANSITIONAL
SERVICES BE AUGMENTED WITH AN
ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WOULD HELP SUPPORT THE
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS
QUARTERS ALL FOURTEEN OF THEM.
WITHOUT FUNDING BEING EVENLY
DIVIDED AMONGST BECAUSE WE
SIMILARLY TO THE CCC.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE
THE SERVICES THAT REALLY HELP
PROVIDE. A LOT OF DIFFERENT.
pORDER FOR THESE YOUTH WHO HAVE
THESE EXTREME BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT AND TO REALLY
REACHING THEIR FULL FULL
POTENTIAL. THESE ARE THE TYPES
OF SERVICES THAT REALLY ADVANCE
THEM AND HELP THEM.
REACH THAT POTENTIAL I'M SO WE
WERE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THAT
IN THAT. IN PREVIOUS YEARS AND
BEFORE THE RECESSION THE EACH OF
THE QUORUM FOR EACH OF THE
INDIVIDUAL CORES USED TO GET
AROUND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE STATE
FOR THESE EXACT SERVICES.
HOWEVER WITH THE RECESSION THEY
ARE NOW ONLY RECEIVING AROUND
TWENTY THOUSAND EACH
SO THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING WOULD
REALLY HELP THEM. PROVIDE I'M
ALL THE PIECES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO EACH OF THOSE YOUTH
I'M REACHING THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE THREE NOW
THAT.
UNDER THE DELTA PROTECTION
COMMISSION THAT.
DELTA TRAIL MASTER PLAN.
ENORMOUS FUNDING REQUEST.
WITH SOME BIG IMPACT OF PLEASE
GREATER ST LEOMINSTER CHAIR
THAT.
PLEASED TO BE HERE MY NAME IS
ERICA BANK I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE DELTA PROTECTION
COMMISSION.
AND WE DON'T OFTEN APPEAR BEFORE
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO COME AND EXPLAIN OUR.
BUDGET REQUEST HERE TODAY GOOD
TO HAVE YOU HERE BUT JUST A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE COMMISSION
IT'S ALWAYS APPRECIATE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INFORM PEOPLE OF
WHO WE ARE AND WHAT WE DO.
FORM DE THE COMMISSION WAS
FORMED IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO
OVER CONCERNED ABOUT
URBANIZATION AT THE PERIPHERY OF
THE DELTA.
AND ONE OF THE EARLY
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
COMMISSION WAS TO PREPARE A LAND
USE PLAN FOR THE DELTA THAT
WOULD.
GUIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENT LAND USE
PLANNING DECISIONS AND THE
COMMISSION ACTUALLY COULD.
ON OCCASION IF IT FOUND A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LAND USE DECISIONS
WERE.
INCONSISTENT WITH THAT PLAN
COULD OVERRULE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OF LAND USE DECISIONS.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE THEIR WORLD
IN THE DELTA CHANGED.
LEGISLATION WAS.
ADOPTED TO CREATE ARE THAT THAT
A FELLOW AGENCY THE DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL WHICH THEN
HAD RESPONSIBILITY FOR ENSURING
THAT.
THE STATEMENT IT'S TWO GOALS FOR
THE DELTA A RELIABLE WATER
SUPPLY AND RESTORATION OF THE
DELTA ECO SYSTEM.
BUT TO ACCOMPLISH THOSE IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS AND ENHANCES THE
UNIQUE DELTA VALUES.
AND THAT'S OUR PRIMARY.
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
COMMISSION NOW IS TO IN.
HELP ADVISE THE STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL ON HOW BEST TO PROTECT
AND ENHANCE THE UNIQUE DELTA
VALUES.
AND THE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTED THE
GREAT CALIFORNIA DELTA TRAIL
ACT.
AND THAT A CHARGE THE COMMISSION
WITH CREATING A TRAIL THROUGH
THE DELTA TO CONNECT THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY TRAIL.
AT THE FAR WESTERN INTO THE
DELTA WITH THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
TRAIL NOT TOO FAR OUTSIDE OF OUR
AT THIS BUILDING HERE.
ALONG THE SACRAMENTO RIVER. AND
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF OUR
REQUEST YOU TODAY IS REGARDING
MASTER PLANNING FOR THAT GREAT
CALIFORNIA DELTA TRAIL.
THAT COULD GOOD REPRESENTATION
ARE JUST THE GENERAL
PRESENTATION AND I'M HAPPY TO GO
INTO DETAIL ON THE ITEM BEFORE
YOU. A PICTURE ETCHER PROP HAVE
LEGISLATION AND A IN A IN A
MOMENT THAT TO WILL GIVE YOU
THATTO AT LEAST A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT OPPORTUNITY BUT JUDGES
ALEJO HAVE CONTACT MITCHELL IS
WITH LA WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS PURPOSE
FINANCE ASSUME NO COMMENTS.
I.
SO CAN YOU JUST.
DESCRIBE.
WHAT THIS AMOUNT OF THIS IS A
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR?
ALLOCATION BUT WHAT WILL THAT
FUNDING CA HELP YOU ACCOMPLISH
SO THAT THE REQUEST IS FOR.
TOOK TO CREATE A MASTER PLAN
FOR THAT THAT DELTA TRAIL WE DO
HAVE. EXCUSE ME WE DO HAVE
DESIGNATED SEGMENTS OF THE TRAIL
AT THE EDGES OF.
OF THE DELTA THE THE EDGES OF
THE DELTA ARE.
GENERALLY URBAN AREAS AND SO WE
DO HAVE DESIGNATED SITES.
TRAIL SEGMENTS THAT EXIST
WITHIN.
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO OF
PORTIONS OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO ARE. WITHIN THE LEGAL
DELTA.
WITHIN THE CITY OF WEST
SACRAMENTO.
LIKEWISE LOCATED WITHIN THE
LEGAL DELTA.
AND THEN ALL THE WAY AT THE FAR
END OF THE DELTA AT SEGMENTS
DESIGNATED WITHIN.
CITIES IN EASTERN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY SO THESE ARE TRAIL
SEGMENTS THAT.
EXISTS THROUGH URBAN AREAS.
THEY WERE DEVELOPED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WE'VE.
BUT OUR SEAL ON THEM AND AND
ADOPTED THEM THE SEGMENTS OF THE
GREAT CALIFORNIA DELTA TRAIL.
THERE'S A LOT OF CONNECTION THAT
NEEDS TO OCCUR BETWEEN THOSE TWO
URBAN AREAS AT THE FAR ENDS OF
THE DELTA.
AND THE PURPOSE OF THE REQUEST
TODAY IS TO COMPLETE AMASTER
PLAN. FOR THAT MORE DIFFICULT.
THAT HAD SEGMENT ACT CONNECTING
WHAT'S LARGELY RURAL LANDS IN
BETWEEN.
THE URBAN AREAS AT THE PERIPHERY
OF THE DELTA.
THERE'S ASSOCIATED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE
TO CLARIFY THE STATUTE THAT.
UNDER THE CURRENT STATUTE SAYS.
WE CAN ONLY REQUEST FUNDING FOR
THIS MAN.
WE ARE WE CAN ONLY COMPLETE WHEN
WE HAVE ALL THE FUNDING AMASSED.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE CREATING
THE TRAIL SEGMENTS OURSELVES WE
ANTICIPATE WORKING WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
IN THERE TRANSPORTATION AND AND
TRAIL PLANNING EFFORTS.
TO HELP GUIDE THE CREATION OF
THIS IN THEN TO DESIGNATE THOSE
SEGMENTS
BUT WE DON'T INTEND OURSELVES TO
BE OUT THERE WITH.
HEAVY EQUIPMENT. YOU KNOW
BLEEDING BLEEDING A TRAIL FOR
THIS THROUGH THE INTERIOR PART
OF THE DELTA.
SO THAT.
AT THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE MASTER
PLAN.
WILL BE.
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL BE
COLLABORATING TO FILL IN THE
PIECES OF THE.
UP OF THE TRAILS WHO I AM
OVERTIME THAT'S PRETTY CAN BE
PRETTY HARD THAT TO PROTECT.
BASED ON FUNDING SOURCES ANOTHER
A. POLITICAL CONSIDERATIONS
WHEN THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY.
BECOME A REALITY. YEAH I IT IT
IT WE AT WE DON'T HAVE A
PREDICTION FOR WHEN THIS.
ULTIMATE LINKAGE WILL OCCUR.
.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT ULTIMATELY
SOME OF IT MIGHT.
NOT EVEN BEYOND ROAD SEGMENTS
YOU KNOW WE HAVE. MANY MANY
MILES OF WATERWAYS THAT TRAVERSE
THROUGH THE DELTA.
A WATER TRAIL IS A POSSIBILITY
FOR PORTIONS OF THIS.
BUT OF COURSE THE WHAT WE HOPE
TO DO IS TO CONNECTED THROUGH.
OF LAND SEGMENTS BECAUSE THAT'S
PRIMARILY HOW YOU KNOW PEOPLE
WOULD.
RECREATION TRAVEL THROUGHOUT
THIS REGION.
ON A TRAIL WHETHER IT BE ON
BIKER FOOT TUMOR EVEN.
POTENTIALLY EQUESTRIAN USES WELL
WHAT SO MANY OF FIVE THESE PLANS
IN THE THE ONE THAT COMES TO
MIND FOR ME IS VIA COASTAL
TRAIL.
I'M A IT.
TAKE DECADES TO.
AT A TO BUILD OUT IT WOULD BE
NICE TO.
SEE IF WE CAN'T FIND A WAY TO
ACCELERATE THE PROCESS OF THAT
IT DOESN'T TAKE MANY DECADES.
PERHAPS COULD TAKE OF A MUCH
SHORTER PERIOD OF TIME. SO
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT HOW AS
AS WE GO FORWARD YOU MENTIONED
DUH.
ANOTHER WORD URBANIZATION THEN.
I ASSUME THAT'S A A CODE WORD
FOR. AYE ENCROACHING DEVELOPMENT
ON ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE
AREAS THAT WAS TAKING PLACE IN
THE PAST IS THAT.
FAIRLY ACCURATE THAT THAT WAS
CERTAINLY THE THE OF WHAT WAS
OCCURRING IN THE EARLY LATE
EIGHTIES INTO THE EARLY NINETEEN
NINETIES THAT LED TO THE
ADOPTION OF THE. DELTA
PROTECTION ACT OF NINETEEN
NINETY TWO WHAT CERTAINLY TRUE
SINCE THAT TIME IS THAT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITHIN THE
DELTA REGION AND THERE ARE FIVE
COUNTIES THAT.
BOB PRIMARILY HAVE THE LAND USE
JURISDICTION OVER WHAT WE CALLED
PRIMARY ZONE OF THE DELTA.
THEY'VE ALL EMBRACED
THE.
OUR IN OUR PLAN FOR THE DELTA
AT.
AND WHETHER IT'S THROUGH THAT
EMBRACING THAT PLANET WHETHER
IT'S BECAUSE FLIGHT RESTRICTIONS
HAVE BECOME MUCH MORE.
DIFFICULT TO GET AROUND IN TERMS
OF DEVELOPMENT THAT WE HAVE NOT
SEEN THAT FURTHER INCURSION OF
URBANIZATION.
INTO THE INTERIOR DELTA AND IT
STE TO THIS DAY REMAINS A.
A REGION THAT'S AGRICULTURAL HAS
A LOT OF NATURAL. RESOURCE VALUE
A LOT OF NATURAL. OF FEATURES
STILL INTACT BUT THAT'S GOOD TO
HEAR.
I THINK I GIVEN THE EXPERIENCE
OF THE LAST FEW YEARS ON WITH
FIRE AND AND AND AND FLOODING IN
EVEN THE RECENT MUDSLIDES WERE.
LEARNING THAT TO HER OF OVER
MANY MANY YEARS WE'VE UP.
.
ALLOWED TO HAVE BUILDING TO
TAKE PLACE IN SOME AREAS WHERE
IT'S JUST REALLY NOT A GOOD
IDEA.
AND I THINK THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT WE HAVE YET TO REALLY GET A
HANDLE ON ALTHOUGH A ENOUGH AT
THE AREA OF YOUR JURISDICTION IT
SOUNDS LIKE A.
THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME PROGRESS
ON THAT WOULD.
MIGHT BE USEFUL TO.
OF FIND A WAY FOR OTHER TO BE
SOME STATEWIDE COLLABORATION ON
WHAT TYPE BEST PRACTICES ARE IN
THAT REGARD SO WE BEGIN TO THINK
ABOUT. THIS ISSUE HOLISTICALLY.
A IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR
INDIVIDUAL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
A.
IT TOOK TOOK THE TO GRAPPLE WITH
THAT ISSUE FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS
BUT I THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE
REALLY NEED TO MAKE GOTTA.
OF PROGRESS ON.
HAD ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
TO HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE SPRINGS INTO ACTION.
THEN THE.
WELCOME MR PATTERSON WE WILL
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
AND IT.
.
LET'S TAKE ROLES AS WE GOT. A
GOOD IDEA WILL FORMER CORRECT AT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A
COMMITTEE OR WHAT.
BLOOM.
HERE FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
IS SAID ISSUE THREE AND ISSUE
THAT.
AND OF MISTER PATTERSON HAS
JUST ARRIVED AND I'M NOT EVEN
GIVING HIM TIME TO CATCH HIS
BREATH BUT.
ALONG TO WE HAVE CONSENSUS ON
ISSUE THREE.
SIR.
RIGHT.
.
WE'RE GONNA BREATHE FOR A
MOMENT.
FINE BUT TAKE YOUR TIME RICHARD.
ALL RIGHT GONNA TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS MOMENT.
ALRIGHT WOULD WOULD BE LIKE TO
MAKE A MOTION.
Q..
BLOOM.
I FONG.
KALRA MULLIN PATTERSON.
THANK YOU.
OFTHANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND NOW WILL MOVE
ON TO THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL. AND THE ISSUE FOR.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
.
MY NAME IS RYAN STEM FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE AND POLICY ADVISER.
AT THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL I'M JOINED HERE BY THE
COUNCIL'S CHIEF DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER JUST CALL LAW.
BOB BY WAY OF BACKGROUND ALL
I'LL BE BRIEF MR VINCA COVERED A
LITTLE BIT OF OF WHAT WE'RE
ABOUT THE SEVEN MEMBER COUNCIL
WAS CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE. WITH ITS PLANNING SCIENCE
AND REGULATORY FUNCTIONS TO
FURTHER THE STATE CO EQUAL GOALS
OF PROVIDING A MORE RELIABLE
WATER SUPPLY.
AND RESTORING THE DELTA
ECOSYSTEM. ALL WHILE BEING
CONSIDERATE OF THE DELTA AS
PLACE.
COMPONENT THIS CHARGES LARGELY
CARRIED OUT TO THE COUNCIL'S
LEGALLY ENFORCEABLE FRAMEWORK
KNOWN AS THE DELTA PLAN.
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THIS MORNING
RELEASE HAS THREE ELEMENTS.
THE FIRST OF A ONE TIME FUNDING
AUGMENTATION TO FURTHER SUPPORT
THE COUNCIL SCIENCE PROGRAM. AND
ITS ROLE AS THE PRIMARY FUNDER
OF OBJECTIVE SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH
IN THE DELTA OUT WHICH IS PAYING
PROVIDE THE CRITICAL FOUNDATION
FOR. AYE DELTA MANAGEMENT
DECISIONS.
AND THEN ADDITIONALLY THE
PROPOSAL SIX PERSONNEL
RESOURCES.
TO SUPPORT ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT
WORK IN THE DELTA AND ADDITIONAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOR THE
ORGANIZATION WITHOUT MISTER
CHAIR. BE HAPPY ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
ALEJO.
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AYE NETS.
ANY QUESTIONS.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
IN MORNING READY THOMPSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
SEVEN CALIFORNIA I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS THE CONTRACTORS DO
HAVE A SUPPORT OF THIS
PARTICULAR BCP. FOUND
PARTICULARLY TO HELP FACILITATE
THAT AT THAT DISTRICT COUNCIL
TAKING A MORE ACTIVE A LEAD ROLE
IN SCIENCE. SO WITH THAT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THIS AN ITEM.
.
THAT.
YOU THINK WE SHOULD MOVE FORWARD
ON.
I THINK.
THANK YOU.
BLOOM. AYE FONG.
KALRA MULLIN PATTERSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WILL MOVE ON TO CAL FIRE.
WELCOME DIRECTOR FINANCE GOOD TO
SEE YOU AGAIN THAT MORNING
LIKEWISE.
WE'LL START WITH THAT ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE.
HE GOOD MORNING CHAIR BLOOM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAN
TELL WHAT DIRECTOR OF HELLFIRE
AND I DO WISH TO OPEN BY JUST
ECHOING DIRECTORS SIDE THOSE
COMMENTS ABOUT.
FIRE SEASON TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE HAVE ALL FACED AS A STATE AND
JUST REALLY WANT TO. EMPHASIZE
THE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS IN
THEIR EFFORTS OF THE YOUNG MEN
AND WOMEN.
OF THAT ORGANIZATION THAT TRULY
MADE A DIFFERENCE NOT ONLY IN
THE RESPONSE TO THESE FIRES BUT
TO THE WORK THEY DO EVERYDAY.
ARE IN RESOURCE PROTECTION OF
FUELS TREATMENT FIRE PREVENTION
AND ALL OF THAT WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT BEFORE YOU TODAY I'D NUMBER
FIVE EVER ARE A VARIETY OF
CAPITAL OUTLAY.
PROJECTS THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
BRINGING FORWARD A AND THIS IT
REALLY STEMS FROM THE BOOK
LONGSTANDING BACKLOG OF
MAINTENANCE NEEDS. ARE WITHIN
CAL FIRES FACILITIES WHICH THREE
QUARTERS OF WHICH.
BILL PRIOR TO NINETEEN FIFTY.
ARE IN A VARIETY OF PROJECTS
THERE IN PARTICULAR.
SUCH AS.
ARE MOVING FIRE STATION OR
PUTTING A FIRE STATION ARE IN
THE NORTH END OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY ODD PROVIDE PROTECTION IN
A CRITICAL AREA OF STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR. OUR
PARTNERS IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
UP BUT THAT THE PROJECTS THERE
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON ITEM
FIVE.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF.
ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
PRESENTATIONS.
IS THERE A.
DESIRE TO HAVE A MOTION ON THIS
ITEM.
THIS ISSUE NUMBER FIVE WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THANK YOU.
WELL. I FALL.
KALRA MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
GREAT THANK YOU ISSUE NUMBER SIX
ISSUE NUMBER SIX IS A MOBILE
EQUIPMENT REPLACEMENT. PROGRAM
BUDGET THIS REQUESTS.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THE REPLACEMENT. OF CAL FIRE.
MOBILE EQUIPMENT A CALIFORNIA
HAS ALMOST THIRTY IVE HUNDRED
VEHICLES THAT INCLUDES OUR FIRE
ENGINES BULLDOZERS AND THE
VARIETY OF SUPPORT EQUIPMENT.
OUR CHIEF OFFICERS FORESTERS AND
OTHERS UTILIZE.
AND AGAIN WITH THE FIRE SEASON
THAT OUT LAST YEAR ROUND THIS
EQUIPMENT IS BEING USED UP EVERY
DAY. NOT ONLY FOR RESPONSE TO
WILDLAND FIRES BUT FOR THE FIRE
PREVENTION AND RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT MISSION. THE
DEPARTMENT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
INCLUDING UP WORK ON PRESCRIBED
FIRE AND OTHER FUELS PROJECTS.
OUR OUR CRITERIA ESTABLISHED BY
THAT WERE THAT WE UTILIZE
ESTABLISHED BY THE NATIONAL FIRE
PROTECTION ASSOCIATION OB WORK
TOWARDS REPLACING IN MOVING THIS
EQUIPMENT OUT OF FRONT LINE
SERVICE.
AFTER TEN YEARS AND THEN
ULTIMATELY MOVING IT OUT OF
RESERVE STATUS AFTER TWENTY.
IT'S NOT JUST THE YEAR CYCLE
BUT IT'S ALSO THE AMOUNT OF
WORKLOAD THESE VEHICLES
EQUIPMENT HAVE IN TERMS OF OFF
ROAD USE PUMPING AND ALL THE
STRESSES THAT ARE PLACED IN THE
ENVIRONMENTS THAT WE. OPERATE IN
SO THE DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING
A ONE TIME FUNDING OF THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND. VOWED TO ALLOW US TO START
INCREMENTALLY DECREASING OF THE
BACKLOG.
TO START INCREASING OUR
REPLACEMENT CYCLE.
Q..
THE BOTTOM.
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE?
TO.
A BRING EVERYTHING.
STUFF OR YOU KNOW AS. A AND.
I'M NOT TO. SURE EXACTLY HOW TO
SAY THIS YEAR YOUR YOUR BEHIND
SCHEDULE IN TERMS OF.
THE IDEAL REPLACEMENT SCHEDULE
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO BRING YOU
CURRENT ON EVERYTHING.
SO THE BATTERED CURRENTLY
APPEARANCE.
I DON'T HAVE AN EXACT NUMBER BE
OBVIOUSLY CAME IN IN WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
TO GET US BACK TO BUT WE'VE
HISTORICALLY BEEN FUNDED AT IN
OUR MOBILE EQUIPMENT REPLACEMENT
BUDGET.
TO TO REALLY WORK TOWARDS THE
FORTY THREE PERCENT.
.
FIVE DEFICIT THAT WE HAVE IN
TERMS OF.
WHERE WERE AT IN THE REDUCTION
OR IN IN THAT? BEING BEHIND THAT
THE POWER CURVE IF YOU WILL ON
REPLACEMENT.
OKAY WELL I'VE.
IF A A IS IT POSSIBLE FOR YOU
TO GET THAT NUMBER ACTUALLY WHAT
WILL HAVE STAFF FOLLOW UP WITH A
SPECIFIC TIME FRAME IN NUMBERS
FOR WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO BRING
US INTO COMPLIANCE WITH
HARASSMENT SCANDAL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S UP.
PROBABLY RIGHT NOW AND I
UNDERSTAND WHY PROBABLY. ALL THE
FLEETS STATEWIDE.
A IN EVERY DEPARTMENT ARE STILL
BEHIND SCHEDULE.
.
I'VE GOT COMING OUT OF THE
RECESSION. AND WERE PLAYING
CATCH UP AND FREQUENTLY IT'S
THE%
STUFF FLEETS THAT ARE THE THINGS
THAT WE TAKE THE LONGEST TO
CATCH UP ON.
THAT.
BECAUSE THAT'S TO INCUR COSTS ON
THE MAINTENANCE SIDE BECAUSE
IT'S THINGS AGE THEY TAKE MORE
MAINTENANCE AT LEAST THAT'S THE
CASE IN MY EXPERIENCE I WOULD
IMAGINE GIVEN THE. USAGE OF.
OF YOUR VEHICLES THAT'S
PROBABLY EVEN MORE SO BUT IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT GIVEN THE.
INCREASING.
A NEED FOR YOUR DEPARTMENT TO
BE READY AND DE AT TO.
MAXIMUM. CAPACITY IN MAXIMUM
READING HAS THAT WE SHOULD.
AT LEAST UNDERSTAND WHAT AMOUNT
OF MONEY IT WOULD TAKE TO GET
YOU TO THAT PLACE WHERE I YEAR
OF THE IDEAL PLACE IN TERMS OF
THE. REPLACEMENT OF YOUR OVERALL
EQUIPMENT.
SO I'D I'D LIKE TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN PENDING RECEIPT OF
THAT INFORMATION BECAUSE WE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER AN AUGMENTATION
TO GET YOU TO THAT PLACE OR AT
LEAST CLOSER TO IT.
MR MON.
THEY MISTER.
THE CHIEF JUST CURIOUS WHAT A
HELLA TENDER IS. NEVER THAT
TERM.
SO I HELOTIALES A SUPPORT UNIT
FOR A HELICOPTER. HELICOPTER CAN
ONLY CARRY SO MUCH IN TERMS OF
ITS CREW ABOUT WATER AND THE
OTHER FIREFIGHTING EQUIPMENT
THAT THE CREW MEMBERS NEED ON
THE HELICOPTER. BUT IT REQUIRES
SUPPORT FUEL.
ADDITIONAL WATER DROPPING
BUCKETS.
OTHER SUPPORT ITEMS THAT FOLLOW.
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THAT VEHICLE
RESPONDS SOMEONE HELICOPTERS
DEPLOYED IT OFF TO GET TO THE
FIRE FIRST BECAUSE OF THE FLIGHT
TIME. BEGINS ITS OPERATION THE
HELL ATENDER SUPPORT UNIT I
FOLLOW SUIT ON THE GROUND
ARRIVES AT THE INCIDENT THEY SET
UP ESSENTIALLY A HELLA BASE SO
THAT ALL OF THE SUPPORT
MECHANISMS TO SUPPORT. OF THE
HELICOPTER WHEN IT LANDS FOR
REFUELING I NEED MINOR
MAINTENANCE OR OTHER ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE NEEDED ON THE GROUND
ALL THAT IS SUPPORTED BY. THAT
TELETECH UNIT.
THAT SUFFER THE RECORD THAT'S H.
E. L. I. A H. E. L. L. A WOULD
BE A DIFFERENT YEAH THANK YOU
HAVE BUT.
OKAY ENOUGH FOR MY SENSE OF
HUMOR. A.
LET'S THAT WE'RE GONNA HOLD THAT
ITEM OPEN.
AND CERTAINLY HAVE A
CONSIDERATE TO AN UPCOMING
MEETING. AND THAT.
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN IS A CRITICAL
AND ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT POINTING
TOWARDS FRONTLINE RESOURCES AND
FIREFIGHTERS AND FIRE FIGHTING
EQUIPMENT THAT WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT IN NEED PARTICULAR WITH
THE CHALLENGING FIRE SEASONS.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
SUPPORT THE ENTIRE OVERALL
OPERATION. OUT LOGISTICALLY
WITH.
FIRE SEASONS THAT ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY LONGER AND MUCH
BUSIER WITH MORE FIRE ACTIVITY
AND MORE COMPLEX FIRES WERE
ORDERING RESOURCES.
NOT ONLY FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA FROM LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES BUT FROM ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY. OTHER STATES
IN FEDERAL AGENCIES AS WELL AS
EVEN INTERNATIONALLY IN THIS
CASE LAST YEAR AUSTRALIA. ARE
ALL ABOUT REQUIRES PROCUREMENT
AGREEMENTS ARE BEING UTILIZED A
SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD INCREASE IN
PROVIDING THE SUPPORT
FIREFIGHTERS NEED FROM. WATER
FIRE HOSE.
FOOD POISON OAK MEDICINE.
WE'RE LITERALLY RUNNING CITIES
ARE OUT THERE AND THE CITIES CAN
BE DEPLOYED FOR A MONTH OR MORE.
UP ALL THAT REQUIRES SIGNIFICANT
LOGISTICAL SUPPORT.
AND DAY TO DAY PROCUREMENT OF
THESE RESOURCES THIS IS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASING THE
WORKLOAD. OUR EVERYDAY ARE ON
OUR ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF US
STATEWIDE SO UP ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN REQUEST ACCOUNTING
STAFFING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
SUPPORT. OUR OF.
TWENTY ONE AT POSITIONS TO
ADDRESS THIS NEED MANY OF THESE
POSITIONS HAVE BEEN FUNDED. ARE
FROM YEAR TO YEAR ARE BASED ON
AUGMENTATION BUT IT'S CLEAR THIS
IS THE NEW NORMANDY SUPPOSITIONS
ARE CRITICAL TO OUR LIST.
EXCESSIVELY PAY OUR BILLS ON
TIME AND SUPPORT THE
FIREFIGHTERS ON THE GROUND TO
GET THEM WITH THE.
THANK YOU.
.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
DIRECTORA AS YOU KNOW.
.
YOU.
PROVIDED ME WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE.
A WHATEVER BASIS DURING THE.
THOMAS FIRE THAT WAS THAT THE.
OF INTER THAT COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS AND I FOUND TO. OF
THE EXPERIENCE TO BE VERY
ILLUMINATING AND EDUCATIONAL.
BUT THE FULL RANGE OF NOT JUST
THE.
A RESPONSE THAT TO ALL THE
AGENCIES INCLUDING YOURS. UP A
PROVIDE BUT THE SCALE OF IT AND
THE ABILITY TO RAMP UP QUICKLY.
.
AND I'D JUST LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF I DON'T WANNA.
I PREDICT THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE AN EXTROVERT BUT I THINK WE
KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE ANOTHER
VAN HOPEFULLY NOT ON THE SCALE.
OF OF THE FIRES THAT WE SAW OVER
THE.
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND BUT IF
YOU COULD WORK WITH EACH OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AT AN APPROPRIATE TIME AND
WHEN IT'S NOT AN IMPOSITION ON
THE.
WORK RICHARD DOING OUT IN THE
OUT IN THE FIELD ON I THINK WILL
BE VERY USEFUL FOR A FOR
EVERYONE TO SEE THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE MEMBERS COME
OUT AND.
KICKED OPPORTUNITY VISIT
INCIDENT BASIS OR EVEN SOME OF
OUR SMALLER.
FIRES THAT OCCUR WERE PERHAPS.
THANK YOU THAT IS OUR MOTION ON
THIS ITEM.
YES MISTER MALLOY. MISTER CHAIR
JUST A QUICK QUESTION I'M SORRY
IF I MISSUS IS IS A ONE TIME OR
AN ON GOING ON GOING ON GOING.
LET'S LET'S GO THROUGH ALL THESE
ITEMS AND THEN WE CAN TAKE A
MOTIONS ON AN INDIVIDUAL IF
THERE IF THERE ARE.
SO WE CAN DO THAT AFTER PUBLIC
COMMENT RATHER THAN BEFORE. AND
SO THAT TAKES US TO ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT FROM STICKING ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT IS EMERGENCY COMMAND
CENTER A SEASONAL STAFF AND THIS
IS ESSENTIALLY TO TURN
PERMANENT.
THE THIRTY FOUR POSITIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN ASSIGNED AS ON GOING.
SEASONAL FIRE CAPTAIN'S THIS
WAS AGAIN A DIRECT RESULT OF THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN WORKLOAD
THAT'S BEEN OCCURRING ALL OF OUR
EMERGENCY COMMAND CENTERS THE
TWENTY ONE. FRONTLINE CAL FIRE
EMERGENCY COMMAND CENTERS ACROSS
THE STATE AS WELL AS OUR TO.
REGIONAL COORDINATION CENTER IS
THE ONE IN RIVERSIDE AND READING
AND THEN OUR SENTIMENTO
COORDINATION CENTER.
HERE.
AT MAJOR CO LOCATED WITH THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES. UP
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN CALL
VOLUME WHEN ONE FIRE I WON
WILDLAND FIRE OCCURS WE MAY GET
AS MANY AS FOUR HUNDRED CELLULAR
TELEPHONE CALLS COMING INTO OUR
EMERGENCY COMMAND CENTER.
REPORTING THAT ONE CALL IN THE
CASE OF THE OCTOBER.
FIRE SIEGE IN THE NORTH BAY OUR
COMMAND CENTER IN ST HALINA. NOT
RECEIVED ALMOST FOUR THOUSAND.
PHONE CALLS ARE OVER THE COURSE
OF A FORTY EIGHT HOUR PERIOD IN
THIS WORK RANGING FROM LITERALLY
OUR COMMAND CENTER STAFF.
WALKING AND TALKING FIRE ENGINE
COMPANY OFFICERS INTO.
HOMEOWNERS WHILE THEY HAD THEM
ON THE PHONE WHO WERE IN PERIL.
TRYING TO CONNECT THEM UP IN AN
EXTREMELY SMOKY CONDITIONS IT'S
ALSO EXPANDING WHEN A FIRE LARGE
FIRE DOES OCCUR OUR COMMAND
CENTER IS THE ORDERING POINT FOR
ALL OF THE RESOURCES. THEY GET
ORDERED INTO THAT EMERGENCY SO
WE HAVE TO RAPIDLY EXPAND THAT
COMMAND CENTER SO THEY HAVE
STAFF TO PROCESS ENGAGING
ORDERING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FIRE ENGINES. LOGISTICS ALL OF
THAT UP THROUGH AUGMENTATION
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SUPPORT. A
THE THESE ADDITIONAL STAFF AND
IT'S CLEAR AS WE GO INTO THIS
NEW NORMAL THESE THIS IS THE
PACE AND SCALE WHICH WHICH WE
ARE NOW OPERATING. TO ASSN TO
MAKE ALL OF THOSE AUGMENTED
POSITIONS PERMANENT.
SO THIS IS REALLY JUST A
RECOGNITION OF REALITY TO.
.
THAT WERE PREDICTING THAT GOING
FORWARD WE'RE GOING TO BE SAYING
OF MORE EVENTS AND MORE YEAR
ROUND EVENTS CORRECT.
ANY QUESTIONS.
YES
.
WHAT OPTIONS DO WE HAVE TO FUND
THESE KINDS OF THINGS GOING FOR
HIM AND I WILL CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THIS IN AND THE NEED IS IS?
CLEAR.
JUST.
I GUESS I'M CONCERNED JUST IN
THE OUT YEARS IF WE DO YOU ENTER
A DEFICIT KIND OF A POSITION AS
ANY THOUGHT BEING GIVEN TO YOU
KNOW.
HOW WE MAINTAIN THESE
EXPENDITURES ACT GOING FORWARD?
IS A VERY GENERAL QUESTION
FORTIETH AND AND. MAYBE
UNANSWERABLE BUT UP I THOUGHT
I'D PUT IT OUT THERE SINCE
WHERE.
COMMITTEE OURSELVES REALLY TO AN
ONGOING.
SIGNATURE.
VERY GOOD QUESTION AND I WOULD
CERTAINLY DEFER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR LONG
TERM YOU KNOW PLANNING WHEN IT
COMES TO THE FUNDING I'M
MECHANISMS FOR THE STATE BUDGET
BUT I WILL TELL YOU FROM. THE
DEPARTMENT'S PERSPECTIVE THE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE THE FIRE
PROTECTION CAPABILITIES
THAT WORD NOT ONLY ASKING FOR
HERE TODAY BUT WE'VE BEEN
SUPPORT AGAIN OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS ARE CRITICAL. TO
MEET THESE CHALLENGES WE NINETY
FIVE PERCENT OF FIRES ARE CAUSED
BY PEOPLE THE PART WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN BOTH THE
NUMBER OF FIRES ON AVERAGE THAT
ARE OCCURRING THROUGHOUT. THE
STATE AS WELL AS THE HAVE SIZE
AND AND IN A CREEK THERE BEING
BURNED THIS TREND ISN'T CHANGING
IT'S NOT DECREASING IT'S ONLY.
GOING TO CONTINUE TO GROW SO WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN OR
INCREASE OUR INVESTMENT.
THE PRESSURE CONTINUES TO COME
BACK ON OUR FIREFIGHTERS TO TO
TO MEET THIS THIS IMPACT AS THE
WORKLOAD INCREASES WERE ASKING
THESE FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT
PEOPLE TO CONTINUE. TO WORK
HARDER AND HARDER EVERY DAY UP
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO IDENTIFY
NOT WHERE WE NEED TO PROVIDE THE
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY. AND
CRITICAL TO PROVIDE THAT LONG
TERM SUPPORT AND ENSURE THAT
IT'S HERE AND READILY IN WHAT
PREPARED IN THE BUDGET TO
INSURANCE CONSISTENT.
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER NINE THE MCCLELLAN RELOAD
BASE.
SO I'M A CO AND RELOAD BASIS A
FACILITY.
RIGHT HERE IN OF THE SACRAMENTO
REGION THAT MCCLELLAN.
AIRPORT IT HAS BEEN OPERATED.
ALMOST ON THE SEASON TO SEASON
BASSIST WE'VE AGAIN RECEIVE
DROUGHT AUGMENTATION TO HAVE
SEASONAL STAFFING THERE THE BASE
HAS PROVEN INVALUABLE. TO
SUPPORT CAL FIRES AND OUR
PARTNERS AT THE FOR SERVICE.
FIRE SUPPRESSION EFFORTS ARE
THROUGHOUT.
CALIFORNIA AND NOT JUST THE
GREATER REGION AROUND
SACRAMENTO.
THIS AIRPORT NOT ONLY CAN
SUPPORT CAL FIRES AIR TANKERS
BUT SUPPORTS BECAUSE OF ITS
SIZE.
UP A LARGE AND VERY LARGE AIR
TANKERS THAT WERE NOW UTILIZING
A IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT
INCLUDES THE SEVEN FORTY SEVEN
WHICH CAN DELIVER ALMOST TWENTY
THOUSAND GALLONS OF RETARDANT.
AB ONE.
FLIGHT OR OR ONE DROP UP WE CAN
ACTUALLY OPERATE THAT AIRCRAFT
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE FROM
MCCLELLAN AND INDEED WAS
UTILIZEDON A NUMBER OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FIRES.
BECAUSE OF THE SHORTENED FLIGHT
TIMES IN AND ITS ABILITY TO
OBVIOUSLY MOVE MOVE QUICKLY INTO
PLOY.
AGAIN WE'VE BEEN.
STANDING THAT UP THROUGH
AUGMENTATION BUT THIS IS A YEAR
ROUND ALMOST YEAR ROUND ACTIVITY
AGAIN IN DECEMBER ON THE THOMAS
FIRE WE WERE ACTIVELY FLYING
AIRCRAFT. FROM MCCLELLAN TO
SUPPORT THOSE FIRES IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL REPRESSIVE BILLY
TO STAFF THAT FOR UP TO AT LEAST
NINE MONTHS.
BOB PERMANENTLY SO WE HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO SUPPORT THESE YEAR
ROUND OPERATIONS
THANK YOU QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE. OF CHART MISTER
CRADDICK IS THAT IS IS THAT
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN.
CALIFORNIA EQUIPMENT OR IS IT.
TOO TO HAVE TO.
WAIT IN LINE TO GET SOMETIMES IF
THEY'RE OTHER FIRES GOING ON
OTHER PLACES WHAT KIND OF A.
RAPID AVAILABILITY.
WHEN WE HAVE A.
THANK
EXPLOSIVE FIRE THAT THAT
REQUIRES IT.
SO IT'S ARE OBVIOUSLY A PRIVATE
VENDOR AND IT IS THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE A UNDER AN EXCLUSIVE USE WE
UTILIZE A THROUGH WHAT WE CALL
CALL WHEN NEEDED.
AND IT IS AVAILABLE.
TO THE FOR SERVICE POTENTIALLY
TO OTHER STATES.
AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA I WILL
TELL YOU WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE VENDOR COMMUNITY AND
OUR PARTNERS AT THE FOREST
SERVICE WHO ARE THE LARGEST
USERS OF THESE AIRCRAFT.
COORDINATE AT THEIR USE AND
ACTIVELY IN WHERE THE FIRE
ACTIVITY IS AND HOW WE CAN BRING
THEM.
INTO WHERE WE NEED THEM IN
ADDITION TO THE SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN WE HAVE ACCESS TO. OTHER
LARGER TANKERS THE DO YOU SEE
TENS THERE ARE THREE OR FOUR
THOSE ARE AVAILABLE AS WELL AS
NUMEROUS LARGE AIR TANKERS THESE
ARE DECISIONS WE LOOK AT AND
MAKE EVERY. YEAR AND THROUGHOUT
FIRE SEASON TO WHERE WE CAN BEST
PUT THOSE BUT CERTAINLY THEY ARE
SUBJECT. OUGHT TO OTHER
DECISIONS AND OTHER USE AND
CERTAINLY NOT JUST IN THE UNITED
STATES DURING FIRE SEASON IN THE
OPPOSITE HEMISPHERE.
THEY ARE UTILIZED BY AUSTRALIA.
AND OTHER COUNTRIES AS WELL.
HAVE YOU RUN INTO AVAILABILITY.
ISSUES.
THAT HAVE EITHER SIGNIFICANTLY
ARE MARGINALLY AFFECTED.
THEIR AVAILABILITY AND THEIR USE
AT CRITICAL TIMES WHEN WE NEEDED
THEM.
UP CERTAINLY WHEN WERE IN FIRE
SEASON THROUGHOUT THE WEST
INTERMOUNTAIN WEST.
AND CALIFORNIA AND NORTHWEST OF
ALL FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES ARE
CERTAINLY IMPACTED WE ELECT WERE
AT ONE POINT DURING THE FIRE
SIEGES IN IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN. YOU HAVE
PUBLIC CLOSE TO TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND FIREFIGHTERS ON THE
FIRE LINE. UP AS WELL AS ALL OF
THE AIRCRAFT THAT ARE AVAILABLE
IN THE COUNTRY AND FROM OUTSIDE
THE COUNTRY. ARE DEPLOYED
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LIMITED
RESOURCE ALL OF THOSE ARE VERY
CLOSELY COORDINATED. BETWEEN OUR
PARTNERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS AT
THE BOISE ON THE NATIONAL FIRE
CENTER THERE IN BOISE. UP TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE HAD ACCESS
TO EVERY AVAILABLE AIRCRAFT IN
THE COUNTRY.
WERE MADE AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIA UTILIZED EVERY
RESOURCE WE THAT WE NEEDED ABOUT
WAS WAS BE UTILIZED AS
APPROPRIATE BUT THESE ARE OF
COURSE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS AND
THE NEXT GENERATION AVIATION
FLEET.
IS RAPIDLY EMERGING WHAT'S WERE
FINDING AND PRICKLY AS OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS NO LOOK AT NEW
AIRCRAFT THAT WE ARE MOVING
INTO.
THAT MANY MORE JET AIRCRAFT AND
WORKING ON BRINGING NEW
PLATFORMS FOR AND CALIFORNIA'S
RIGHT THERE ARE WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO. IDENTIFY THOSE NEW
AIRCRAFT IN THE SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OUT
WE LEAD THE CHARGE WITH THE
FOREST SERVICE TO ENSURE. THAT
THE SEVEN FORTY SEVEN ABOUT HAD
WHAT IT NEEDED TO BE CARDED AND
UTILIZED AS FIREFIGHTING
AIRCRAFT.
IN CALIFORNIA SO WE CONTINUE TO.
TO WORK WITH THEM TO ENSURE ALL
THESE AIRCRAFT HAPPENING ARE
COMMITTED TO CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.ISSUE NUMBER TEN OUR
FINAL ISSUE.
IS SAID THE.
.
SELF CONTAINED BREATHING
APPARATUS REPLACEMENT PROGRAM.
SO SELF CONTAINED BREATHING
APPARATUS THIS IS.
PROPOSAL TO OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS UP WHOLESALE
REPLACE CAL FIRES A SELF
CONTAINED BREATHING APPARATUS.
OF TO THAT THE NEW CURRENT
STANDARD AND THAT BRINGS UP INC
COMPLIANCE WITH THE NFPA
NATIONAL FIRE PROTECTION
ASSOCIATION STANDARDS. ARE AS
WELL AS THE INTER OPERABILITY
NEEDS THROUGHOUT THE FIRE
SERVICE THESE ARE THAT THE
FRONTLINE PIECES OF SAFETY
EQUIPMENT THAT FIREFIGHTERS USE
WHEN THEY'RE. RESPONDING TO ANY.
DANGEROUS OUR ATMOSPHERE AND
YET EVEN OUR IN OUR WILDLAND
FIREFIGHTERS ARE OTHER FIVE ALL
OF OUR FIREFIGHTERS AND CAL FIRE
RESPOND ALL TYPES OF FIRES
VEHICLE FIRES. UP START WILDLAND
FIRES AND SO IT'S CRITICAL THAT
OUR FIREFIGHTERS HAVE.
PROTECTION FROM THE TOXINS THAT
COME FROM ALL THESE DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENTS AND NOW BRINGING UP
THE STANDARD SO THAT WE MEET ALL
OF THE CURRENT. HAZARDS
MATERIALS GUIDELINES IF THE
EQUIPMENT IS NOT STATE OF THE
ART SO PROVIDES OF THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF PROTECTION FOR
FIREFIGHTERS AND INTER OPERABLE
WITH OUR FIRE SERVICE.
PARTNERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SINCE WE ALL RESPOND
INTERCHANGEABLY THROUGH THE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM.
ON ON CALLS TOGETHER TO THIS
MALL OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS
REPLACE ALL OF THOSE WITH THE
CURRENT STANDARD IN PROVIDING
ONGOING MAINTENANCE.
A PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
EQUIPMENT IS MAINTAINED TO THE
APPROPRIATE STANDARD.
AND THE END OF THE YEAR VIEW
DOES THIS ALLOCATION AND THE
ABOUT THE PROGRAM THAT IT
REPRESENTS.
.
PROVIDE THE.
THE APPROPRIATE A REPLACEMENT
SCHEDULE OR IS THERE A A IS A
SPIKE THAT PRIOR ITEM IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT IS.
I'M TAKING A LITTLE BIT LONGER
BECAUSE OF.
.
THE PERCEIVED LACK OF FOR OF
FOLK ONETIME RESOURCES.
NO I'M VERY PLEASED WITH THIS
REPLACEMENT CYCLE ADDED THREE
AND THAT'S APPROXIMATELY THREE
YEARS TO GET THESE REPLACED.
LOGISTICALLY STRUCTURALLY THAT
WOULD WORK WELL FOR US ANYWAY AS
WE CYCLE THESE THROUGH SOME VERY
HAPPY WITH THIS
GREAT GREAT FENDER MADE WE CAN
NOW MOVE THIS ITEM FORWARD LET'S
TAKE A THERE'S NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS. LET'S TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
ON.
ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA ITEMS ANY
OR ALL OF THEM.
RICHARD GARRETT JR BLOOM
COMMITTEE. AND DIRECTOR.
.
YEAH IT IT SHOULD BE A. IS
OBVIOUS THAT.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY.
CAL FIRE.
THIS IS A FOREMOST STATE OF
EMERGENCY IN THE FIRE PROTECTION
IN THE UNITED STATES. AND IF NOT
IN THE WORLD AS AN ENTITY
ITSELF.
AND PART OF THE SERVER JUNIOR
COUSIN OF A CALIFORNIA.
IS A RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
DIVISION.
AND I THINK BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT OF TALK THERE'S LEGISLATION.
BUT FOREST HELPED IN DEALING
WITH THESE ISSUES IN A
COMPREHENSIVE MANNER. ALLOW THIS
GOES BACK TO RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
IS REALLY DIFFICULT.
THEY HAVE THE KIND OF FOCUS IT'S
NEEDED A RESOURCE MANAGEMENT'S
EASY.
THIS IS A MAJOR EMERGENCY
BITING.
AGENCY.
AT SOME OF THE.
BASIC PROBLEMS.
STAND BACK GUY IF NOT FIFTEEN
YEARS EVEN MORE BUT YOU ALL
SHOULD REMEMBER I LOVE.
SAYING THIS TO DIVERSE AUDIENCES
IN THEN HERE THE GAS DOES HAVE
MORE IMPACTS.
THAT WAS IN EFFECT FROM NINETEEN
FORTY SIX TO NINETEEN.
OF SEVENTY SIX
WHEREBY FOREST LANDOWNERS OUR
TAX EVERY YEAR UNDERSTANDING
TIMBER.
UNTIL THEY CUT SEVENTY PERCENT
OF IT.
OKAY.
SO THIS LATITUDE LEGACY PROBLEM
WE HAVE TODAY. IN THE FIFTY FIVE
AND SIXTY FOUR FLOODS.
EXACERBATED THAT DAMNED
EXTREMELY.
SO AND. THERE WAS LEGISLATION.
AND A BECAME LAW TWENTY TWELVE
AB FOURTEEN NINETY TWO.
YOU TAKE NOTE OF THOSE NUMBERS.
BUT IT GIVES AGO THRESHOLD A
WATERSHED MOMENT.
BECAUSE.
AT.
THAT BILL GAVE A CAPITA FORCE
FOR A LIABILITY TO LANDOWNERS.
EXTENDED TIME OF HARVEST PLANS
AND CREATED A FUNDING SOURCE FOR
FORCED REGULATION AND SO CALLED
FOREST RESTORATION.
I AND THE TAX
AND RETAIL AMBER PRODUCTS.
AND IT'S A BRING IN OVER FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO IT ALSO CREATED AND A
POSITIVE SIDE FOR A LOT OF
PUBLIC.
.
INTENSE TO ACTUALLY DEAL FORCE
RESTORATION WATERSHED
RESTORATION CARBON SEQUESTRATION
ALL OF THIS AND SO I'M APPEARING
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
TO LOOK AT IT FROM A BUDGET
BASIS AND I FEEL. I AND MANY
OTHERS DO ALSO THAT THE
ALLOCATION OF THOSE FUNDING.
FOR THE FUNDING.
THAT IT.
PROMOTES THE PERSONALITY FOCUS.
HAS NOT BEEN ADEQUATE HEARING
IRAN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
AND A LOT OF THE BASIC CHANGES
ABOUT AT OBSERVED DATE DATA
ORGANIZATION IS LIKE A LOT A
TOWER OF BABEL.
WITH THE DOOR EIGHT BETWEEN
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND BETWEEN
FORESTERS AND YOU PUT
INFORMATION ON HARVEST PLANS TO
REPORT YOUR ISSUE DIFFERENT
SYMBOLS.
NEW THE IS A WHOLE NEED
UPGRADING THAT THAT LEGISLATION
WAS SUPPOSED TO DO THAT.
SO.
.
BERNIE IS RE SOME REALLOCATION
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I'M
FAMILIAR WITH BECAUSE I'M.
INVOLVED WITH THIS PILOT PROJECT
WAS REALLY IMPORTANT PAYING TO
HAVE.
PLANNING WATERSHED PILOT
PROJECTS TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT
REAL HARVEST PLANS AN OPENING
WATERSHED SCALE WHICH IS A
SCALED A COMPLETE IMPACTS ARE
CONSIDERED AT TO SEE WHAT'S WERE
SAVING WITH WORTH. CHANGING TO
MAKE IT A STREAMLINED PROCESS.
TO DEAL WITH FORCE RESTORATION
KNOWLEDGE YOU NEED TO KNOW THAT
HIGH GRADING OUR SIXTEEN INCH IN
DIAMETER TREES.
NO LISTEN SOME FAILURE TO
ACTUALLY MAINTAIN THE KIND OF
FORCED TO PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
FORCED FELT. BITS OLD ENOUGH AND
PROBABLY ENOUGH TO HELP TO
SUPPRESS WILDFIRES IN TO GIVE
ECONOMIC AND ECOLOGICAL BENEFIT
TO BE TRANSPARENT TO THE PUBLIC
INCLUDING LEGISLATURE.
SO I WOULD THE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
BECOME EDUCATED ON THAT I. HAD
TO HAND OUT THERE ABOUT LAST
CHANCE ABOUT MAYBE FOURTEEN
NINETY TWO IN THE TIMBER
REGULATION COURSE RESTORATION.
OF FUND PROGRAM.
AND AND.
ROSS HENLEY WHO'S HERE WE COME
THE TIMBERS ARE. USED TO BE A
CAL FIRED HIS WAS RESOURCES
AGING HOUSE FLUFFY PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN CAL EPA. AND THE US
RESOURCES AGENCY TO TAKE ON
THESE FORCE MANAGEMENT ISSUES
THAT ARE ROUTE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO DEAL
WITH.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN TERRY MCHALE WITH ERIN
REGAN ASSOCIATES
I'M GONNA BE HELLA BRIEF HERE
MISTER CHAIRMAN. A.
COUPLE OF THINGS FIRST OF ALL.
AARON AND I READ THE ANALYSIS
THIS MORNING AND IT WAS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY WELL WRITTEN
ANALYSIS
AND IT HIGHLIGHTED NOT ONLY HOW
HEROIC OUR FIREFIGHTERS ARE FROM
THE TOP TO THE BOTTOM. BUT HOW
MUCH THEY DO WITH LESS
WE REALLY APPRECIATED JUST HOW
YOU DELINEATED THAT.
A THERE'S GOING TO GO A LETTER
GOING TO THE GOVERNOR IT'S GOING
TO BE SIGNED BY MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
IT'S MAKING TWO SEPARATE
REQUEST.
THE FIRST REQUEST IS A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PRE
POSITIONING.
OR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION FOR PRE
POSITIONING THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ENHANCEMENT OF
THE COMMUNICATION SYSTEM. THAT
COMES FROM THE LOCAL CHIEFS AND
THEIR COALITION. LOCAL TWO EIGHT
EIGHT ONE CAL FIRE SUPPORTS
THAT.
SECOND OF RECOMMENDATION IS
EIGHTY THREE MILLION IT IS
EIGHTEEN MILLION FOR.
ENGINES THAT HAVE BEEN LOST
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
CAL FIRE IN SIXTY FIVE MILLION
TO MAKE UP. FOR THE. THE
STAFFING OF THE ENGINES AND TO
BACKFILL THE EXTRAORDINARY WORK
THAT CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTERS DO WE
HAVE FIREFIGHTERS WERE ON THE
LINE FOR WEEKS AT A TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT TO HAVE FOR MOTIONS ON.
.
ISSUES STUFF FIVE SEVEN EIGHT
NINE AND TEN.
REMINDING YOU THAT TO WORK
HOLDING.
WE DID FIVE.
OKAY WITTE NOT RECALLING WE TOOK
ABOUT AN HOUR AND A ISSUE FIVE.
AND WE'RE HOLDING OPEN ISSUE SIX
SO THAT LEAVES AT SEVEN EIGHT
NINE TEN.
AND YOU HAD SOME QUESTIONS I
THINK.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT.
.
DO ARE FAST SEVEN ARE ALL OF
THEM.
ALRIGHT BUT THE BLOOM AYE FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON YET
OFFICIAL A QUESTION PRESHEAF YOU
BEING HERE UP. I DON'T THINK
THIS IS THE THAT THE APPROPRIATE
BUDGET STUFF THAT WE CAN LOOK AT
AND I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE GONNA.
IF WE'RE GONNA SEE YOU AGAIN
WITH RESPECT TO COMMUNICATION
BUDGET COMMUNICATIONS AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS I JUST WANTED
TO.
SUGGEST THAT I'M A.
DO HAVE SOME SOME CONCERNS AND
WANT TO GET INTERESTED IN.
SOME OF THE COMMUNICATION
CHALLENGES AND SOME OF THE INTER
OPERABILITY ISSUES.
IT SEEMS TO ME WITH THE.
LARGE AMOUNT OF FIRES AND ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT.
AGENCIES THAT ARE.
A IT IT INTER ACTIVE UP ON THE
SCENE.
THE COMMUNICATIONS.
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT ELECT
UNDERSTAND.
YOUR INNER OPERABILITY ISSUES.
IN IN SOME DETAIL IN THAT WOULD
WELCOME AN OPPORTUNITY GET
BRIEFED BY THAT.
AT MY OFFICE SAID SOON OR IN THE
FUTURE.
BUDGET OVERSIGHT.
WHERE COMMUNICATIONS MAY BE ON
THE AGENDA?
DEPARTMENT TO BE HAPPY TO DO
BOTH WITH YOUR BE HAPPY TO VISIT
AND I WALK THROUGH THAT AND AND
THE CHALLENGES THEREIN AND HOW
THE PROCESS WORKS AND CERTAINLY
IN THE IN THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
I'M GLAD I'M GLAD TO DO IT IN AN
OF. A.
BUT ONE ON ONE A UNLESS THERE'S
SOME INTERESTING THAT THE WHOLE
THE WHOLE COMMITTEE LOOKING AT
IT ABSOLUTE SECONDLY IS.
.
WITH RESPECT TO THE PRESCRIBED
BURNS.
AND SOME OF THE OTHER CONTRACTS
THAT WE'RE. THAT THEY'RE THERE
IF IT APPEARS TO BE SOME.
CONFLICT WITH FIRST WITH
RESPECT TO THE LIABILITY THE
INDEMNIFICATION CLAUSES THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS ON PRESCRIBED
BURNS.
AND IT'S BEEN RAISED TO MY
ATTENTION BY AN AWFUL LOT OF THE
FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT TO HAVE.
OLDER CONTRACTS THAT SAY ONE
THING AND NEWER CONTRACTS THAT
SAY THE ANOTHER. AND THERE'S
BEEN SORT OF AN AMBIGUITY HERE
ABOUT.
IT AT.
AT AND I'M I'M I'M ALSO
CONCERNED WHETHER. THIS TOUCHES
ON THE ISSUES WERE FACING OUR
UTILITY ON.
ENERGY COMMITTEE WITH RESPECT TO
THE THE BURNS.
INVERSE CONDEMNATION.
HUGE LIABILITIES COURT CASES
THAT HAVE.
SORT OF INFORMED A THAT THE
THESE LIABILITY ISSUES.
AND I WANT TO UNDERSTAND.
HOW THAT IS AFFECTING THE
PRESCRIBED BURNS THEIR
USABILITY?
OF THEIR VIABILITY AS WE SEE
THESE
S. CONTRACTUAL LANGUAGE.
SHIFT.
IT IT APPEARS TO
SOMEONE OF AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE WITH YOU ON THAT AS WELL
ABOUT KNOW WHETHER THAT'S GOING
TO COME IN FUTURE. BUDGET
OVERSIGHT WE CAN DO IT APP ONE
ON ONE.
VERY HAPPY TO COME TALK ABOUT
THAT TOO AND IT IS ABSOLUTELY
THE THE CENTER OF DISCUSSION WE
WE WE TALKED A LOT TODAY AND
OTHER TIMES ABOUT THE RESPONSE
PIECE.
AND THE FIRE PROTECTION
RESOURCES.
BUT THE WHOLE PART OF A FOR TO
GET AHEAD OF THE CHALLENGE WE
FACE IN CALIFORNIA IS ENGAGING
IN THE FRONT AND THEN THE FUELS
TREATMENT. FIRE PREVENTION AND
PRESCRIBED FIRE IS IT'S VERY
SIGNIFICANT.
COMPONENT AS IDENTIFIED BY THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION AND AND
MANY OTHERS. WORKING THROUGH
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED MANY OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT YOU JUST
BROUGHT UP ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON RELATIVE TO. LIABILITY
AND.
WE GOT IT ARCHAIC LANGUAGE AND
AGREEMENTS WE HAVE.
CAPACITY AND.
WERE THESE ARE THINGS WE ARE
VERY OPENLY DISCUSSING AND
WORKING ON A. GOVERNOR'S VERY
INTERESTED.
AND HOW WE CAN INCREASE.
AND AND PROVIDE BETTER SUPPORT
THERE IT'S A VERY HAPPY TO SIT
DOWN AND BEHAVE YOU ABOUT THAT.
GUT AND WEBER WOULDN'T AYE
OTHERS.
HAVE A NUMBER OF THESE
PRESCRIBER AND BILLS ETCETERA
WERE RUNNING AS WERE.
VETTING THEM AND MOVING THEM
FORWARD RUNNING INTO SOME OF
THESE AMBIGUITIES EVERYONE KINDA
STRAIGHT NOSE OUT AT.
AT LEAST UNDERSTAND.
SO WE APPRECIATE THANK MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU.
THAT BEFORE WE ADJOURN WE'RE
GOING TO.
RECALL THE ITEM SO THAT.
.
WE CAN HAVE AT ON VOTES AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
ATTENDING OUR MEETING TODAY.
REMEMBER THIS MEANING IT'S LIKE
AN ECLIPSE THAT HAPPENS ONCE
EVERY THIRTY FIVE YEARS WERE. IN
UNDER AN HOUR.
THREE.
.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
ISSUE FOR KALRA.
ISSUE FIVE.
KALRA.
ISSUE SEVEN THREE TEN COLOR.
THANK YOU WERE INJURED.
WE HOPE.
GOOD JOB MISTER KALRA.
TURN NEXT